Sometimes when you're
working on managing focus,
it can be possible to get
a little carried away.
Let me show you an example.
So here I've got an autocomplete widget.
I can press the Tab key to focus it.
I can start typing, which will
give me this list of city names.
I can press the down key to focus one.
And then can press Tab again
to complete the selection.
Now, the next thing I want to do is
move to this next field by pressing Tab.
So I'll hit Tab once more.
Hm, and
it looks like I'm not going anywhere.
I think what's happening is,
this autocomplete thinks I'm still
trying to finish my complete action.
So no matter how many times I press
Tab I'm just sort of stuck here.
This is what's known as a keyboard trap.
And it can be very frustrating for
users.
In fact, Section 2.1.2 of the WebAIM
checklist specifically calls this out.
Stating, the keyboard focus
should never be locked or
trapped at any one
particular page element.
The user should be
able to navigate to and
from all page elements
using just their keyboard.
But strange as it may seem,
there are times when this
behavior is actually desirable.
Take for instance, the modal window.
Now, normally when a modal
window is displaying on screen,
we don't want the user to be able to
access any of the content behind it.
Oftentimes developers will add
an overlay to cover the page, but
that doesn't stop keyboard focus
from accidentally traveling
outside of the model.
Here, I'll tab through this dialog.
So I'll press the Tab key,
which will focus the Decline button.
I'll tab again,
which focuses the Accept button.
And I tab one more time.
No, it looks like our focus has
now moved behind the modal window.
Now in instances like this what we
want is a temporary keyboard trap to
ensure that we track focus within
the modal wall it's displaying.
And then that we can restore it to the
previously focused item once the model
is closed.
This can be a tricky
technique to implement, and
while there are proposed ideas on how
to make it easier for developers.
For instance,
like this dialogue element here,
they don't currently have
widespread browser support.
Meaning, we're going to have
to roll up our sleeves and
implement this ourselves.
So here's an example of what
I'm going to try to build.
I've got a little open modal
button up here in the top corner.
And when I focus it and
hit Enter, I get a modal dialog.
I can tab through it, and
the focus is trapped.
I can hit that button and
it'll close it.
I can open it again, and I can hit
Escape or click the background, and
it'll close it and
restore focus to that button.
So this is what I'm going to work
on right now in my code editor.
So, switching to my HTML, I'll start
off by creating a button element,
which I'm going to call modal-toggle.
That's going to be that little
Open Modal button you saw up there
in the corner.
Then I'm going to have a div,
which will hold all of
the content from my modal window.
I'm going to give it that class modal.
Inside of here I've got some text.
And I've got some input fields for
the user to sign up for our newsletter.
And lastly, we've got a little
sign up button down here,
which we're going to call signup.
Clicking this will close
our middle window.
We've also got a modal overlay
down here at the bottom.
That's going to be that
sort of gray background.
Clicking that should
also close the modal.
Okay, so that's our HTML markup,
now let's look at our JavaScript.
Over in our JavaScript, I'm going to
start by creating this variable
called focusedElementBeforeModal.
This is where I'm going to store a
reference to the element that had focus
before we open the modal.
When we close the modal, we want to
restore focus back to this element.
Then I'm going to use
document.querySelector to select both my
modal and my overlay.
I'm also going to use querySelector
to select my modalToggle button.
And I'm going to add an eventListener
to modalToggle to listen for
the click event, which is going
to run this openModal function.
Inside of the openModal function we're
going to take that focusedElement
BeforeModal reference and we're going
to grab the document.activeElement and
store it there.
We're going to listen for
keydown events.
And call this trap keyboard function,
which I'll get to in a moment.
We're also going to listen to
indicators for us to close our modal.
So, if someone clicks on modalOverlay,
we're going to close the modal.
And if someone clicks on the signupBtn
that's contained within the modal,
we're also going to close the modal.
And the next thing we're going to do,
is we're going to try and
figure out all the focusable children
that are inside of the modal dialogue.
To do this I'm going to
create this huge query string
of potentially focusable elements.
And I'm going to call
modal.querySelectorAll
using that string.
So this should give me a grouping
of everything within my modal
window that could
possibly receive focus.
And what I want to do,
is I want to figure out what
the first element in that group is.
And what the last element
in that group is.
And the idea here is these can act
sort of like sentinel elements.
So, if the user is tabbing
through the modal window and
they reach the last focusable element or
the lastTabStop.
And they press Tab again,
we're going to loop them around and
put them on the firstTabStop.
Similarly, if they're on the
firstTabStop, and they press Shift+Tab,
we're going to loop them around and
put them on the lastTabStop.
Next, we're just going to tell
the modal window to display itself.
So we'll set its style to display block.
And we'll also set
the modalOverlay to display block.
And then we're going to focus that
firstTabStop child inside of it.
Now from this point on, if the user
starts to press a key on their keyboard,
we're going to check to see
if they've hit the Tab key.
Now using a modifier key,
they could have hit Shift+Tab.
And if they've hit Shift + Tab,
what we're going to do,
is we're going to first figure out,
are they currently on the firstTabStop?
If they are, let's wrap them around
to the lastTabStop and call focus.
If they haven't hit a modifier key and
they've just hit Tab by itself,
then we'll sa,
are they currently on the lastTabStop?
If they are, we're going to wrap them
around to the firstTabStop and focus it.
Now we're also going to add
a listener for the Escape key.
So if they've hit the Escape key,
we're just going to go ahead and
close the modal.
The closeModal method is
pretty straightforward.
We're going to tell
the model to display none.
We'll tell the overlay to display none.
And then we'll use that reference for
that first focused element.
And we're going to call focus
on it again to restore focus.
So in this case, it'll restore focus
back to that open model toggle button.
Now I realize this is a ton of code.
I sort of think of
the accessible model window as
one of the boss battles
in accessibility.
So, what I want you to do in
the next lesson is use some of this
code to implement
a modal window yourself.
And that way you'll have a deeper
understanding of how all of this works.